mine's way worse than yours what you
kicked a
cat hi I'm Leon I'm Veronica I'm Robbie
I'm Catherine I'm steeven I'm Michael
and we're going to take a BuzzFeed quiz
to see how we've ruined Christmas
describe yourself in one word smart
introverted goofy ambitious generous
dramatic or we can choose a word I'm
doing introverted dramatic goofy Michael
can you please describe me in one word
mean I I was going to say stupid mean
and stupid can I use two words you're
not mean you're not mean or stupid who
do you spend the holidays with immediate
family extended family friends my
partner in-laws by myself my extended
family what about you well my immediate
family's dead not putting that one I
think I'll put friends pick your
favorite Christmas tree I don't know
what that is is that is that a palm tree
I'm picking that one I'm going to go for
like a classic Christmas tree green a
bit of ornaments but not too crazy
finish this sentence in one word when I
was a kid holidays in my house were
quiet chaotic magical formal boring
casual well when I was a kid they were
probably magical I'll probably put that
I used to think puppets were
alive okay I'm going into magical my mom
worked really hard guess I'm going to do
magical too cuz I want to be like you
guys finally what's your favorite part
of the holidays delicious treats the
gift of giving and receiving shopping
decorating seeing my loved ones the
Christmas jams the
food the food I like to eat I'm supposed
to pick seeing my loved ones but my
heart's telling me shopping no no I I
don't like the shopping I like the
giving and receiving or the delicious
treats I'd probably say the gift of
giving and receiving cuz I am both
selfless and
selfish boom I'm picking the shopping
for my family a that's nice that is nice
that's the really fun part you're a good
person that's the difference between me
and you how I ruined Christmas on
Christmas morning you woke up early and
went to your favorite department store
unfortunately you got lost in the store
and you were so frustrated that you
started knocking over displays oh God
and yelling at the sales associates you
joined your friends for Christmas hoping
for a festive time but as usual you
silly and ruined the holiday you wrapped
presents with toilet paper you lit
candles too close to the fireplace and
set the wreath on fire to make matters
worse you accidentally set off the store
alarm while trying to escape you know
that sounds like you that does sound
like me okay that would be something
that I would do the final straw was when
you accidentally knocked over the tree
sending ornaments flying everywhere that
is word by word is the plot of
exmas you arrived at your family's
Christmas gathering with a batch of
homemade cookies that your mother-in-law
is sure to love but as your
mother-in-law bites into the cookie she
spits out in disgust turns out you
accidentally use salt instead of sugar
if your family spends a rest of the day
trying to choke down salty cookies while
giving you the side eye I did that
almost exactly that during an April
fools where I switched the salt to sugar
and my grandma baked a pie yeah she made
an April Fool's pie and they put her in
a home they kind of thought and then I
got yeah and then I got in a lot of
trouble as I sh you wake up on Christmas
morning excited to see your family you
go to open the front door but
accidentally kick your family cat into
the snow you knock over the Christmas
tree ornaments fall and chatter
including your mom's prize glass snowman
maybe next year you should just stay in
bed mine's way worse than yours what you
kicked a cat yeah there's a lot of
things happening here I'm hurting
animals and breaking things in the house
I'm not having Christmas with these
people ever again okay so we all found
out how we are going to be spending our
Christmas 2023 check us out in
x
[Music]
s